- Is it?
- It is, right?
- I don't know.
- I think it is.
("Good Old Boys")
- I'm really excited to try out
all these exotic American unknown things
like chips and more chips.
- This doesn't have a Mexican.
What the hell?
This has a Mexican.
- I really don't get the point of
making Mexican flavors
and calling it American.
Again, it says hot sauce
and it's not spicy.
- This is really, really spicy, man.
- I think you guys
really underestimate us.
We can have a lot of spice.
- I'm saying that as an
Indian, this is spicy.
- Ranch, I don't know what
ranch has to do with it.
- I know flavors like apple or banana,
but I don't know what
a cool ranch there was.
- Not bad.
- Oh.
- No.
- So yeah, it's quite cheesy
and it's lacking some flavor.
- Not bad.
- My life's over.
- This is the better one.
This is the winner.
- Onion rings and fun.
- OK, they better be fun.
They don't look fun.
- There are no onions.
- Hmm, they're Funyuns.
- Smell of onion?
- No.
- Are these Funyuns or Pringles?
- Oh yeah, that is good.
- How do you actually have fun with this?
- Bro, like this.
- Bro, it's like--
- Bro, let's go like thug.
- Yeah, I could snack on this for hours.
- I want some more rings.
- No, no, no. I think this is...
- Probably if I eat too much of this
I'm gonna die.
- On your knees, bro.
Peace.
- We don't really have turkey in India,
not even the dried version.
I've only had cooked meat.
- I don't know if I wanna
put this in my mouth.
- It doesn't look extremely
appetizing at all.
- It's like a chicken that I bought
and I kept it in the fridge,
and I forgot about it.
- I'm gonna break a tooth.
- Let me just concentrate
on the chewing for a bit.
- I give up.
- It tastes normal, but--
- It tastes good, but it's like--
- It's tough, man.
It's like chewing through rocks
and then realizing that
there is nothing soft inside.
- Yeah, it's just basically raw meat.
I like it.
- We get Cheetos here,
but I've never heard of
flaming hot Cheetos--
- Yeah.
- In my life.
- It's exceptionally and alarmingly red.
- Like a baby dragon.
(Man in Red Shirt laughs)
- This looks like kurkure.
- Somebody put a lot of
Schezuan sauce on kurkure.
- Plastic again.
More plastic.
- With cheese.
- I love this.
This is insane.
- It's not flaming hot though.
- The fire wants to come out.
- Yeah.
- But it just can't.
- But it does taste really good.
- This would do so good over here.
- This will kill over here.
- This would (bleep) kill over here.
- Only thing about the American snacks,
they lead astray.
- Nah, nah. Indian snacks all the way.
I like my samosas and my jelly bees.
- Possibly can't imagine
myself having this
again and again and again (mumbling).
- You know the packaging
that these guys have is so
in your face--
- It's very in your face.
- Our product really good.
- I hope you guys have rice and stuff
somewhere in your diet
because if you're having
Doritos every day, boy.
("Good Old Boys")